café au lait s'il vous plaît un double
Express votre barista préféré pourrait
vous le confirmer la diversité de café
n'a jamais été aussi abondante
le café aux champignons nouveaux venus
dans l'offre caféiné mais pourquoi donc
suscite-t-il un intérêt j'avais envie de
pouvoir consommer mon café profiter des
bienfaits donc on a marié les deux et on
a intégré les champignons médicinaux
dans notre routine quotidienne Maeva
costaud dohat et la co-fondatrice de
l'entreprise montréalaise moshop qui
propose quatre variétés de café
fonctionnels contenant plusieurs espèces
de champignons on travaille avec cinq
champignons principalement le reichi qui
est dans toutes nos recettes on a le
théorie
main le coliseps et le fameux chaga roi
des champignons
tous les champignons utilisés dans les
cafés moshop proviennent de la
champignonnière urbaine FNG seul le
capricieux chaga qui met plusieurs
années pour arriver à maturité et
récolter en forêt c'est également ici
que le mycologue Joffroy Renault
transforme ses champignons en extrait
qui seront ensuite infusées au café
parlons du processus comment on en
arrive là
on trouve une façon de le rendre liquide
d'avoir un substrat liquide que ensuite
on va intégrer dans le grain de café la
majorité des entreprises telles que la
gatinoise de givy offre un café
instantané auquel on ajoute de la poudre
de café la compagnie américaine for
sigmatique une des pionnières les vend
déjà moulues alors que chez moshop ont
mis sur les grains entiers je suis une
puriste j'aime le café j'étais baristage
j'adore le goût il faut que ça kick
j'avais envie de respecter le grain
aussi respecter le produit c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille avec des
microtorefacteurs Montréalais
depuis des millénaires on utilise des
champignons dit médicinaux dans
plusieurs pays d'Asie chez nous on les
trouve sur les tablettes des commerces
d'aliments naturels depuis quelques
années et de plus en plus mélangé à des
boissons comme le café
en grain moulu ou instantané plusieurs
marques ont un point en commun elles
misent sur les bienfaits à l'aiguille
sur la santé
les premiers effets qui vont être
notoires ça va être les palpitations
l'anxiété que va provoquer souvent la
consommation de caféine et en intégrant
le rachis on arrive à contrôler tout ça
et à rebalancer en fait la gestion de la
caféine par le corps pour pouvoir
ressentir les effets comme la
stimulation cognitive ça va être quand
même sur à peu près une semaine ou deux
semaines de consommation on attribue des
propriétés thérapeutiques à certaines
espèces de champignons sous forme de
poudre ou d'extraits mais est-ce encore
le cas pour des grains de café infusés
de champignons médicinaux
[Musique]
et qui était rajouté dans votre café
normalement la dose doit être très très
faible et puis je doute qu'on puisse
retrouver certains bienfaits est-ce que
c'est scientifiquement prouvé que
certains champignons ont des bénéfices
sur la santé
la réponse à ça c'est non en général
bien que il y a eu quelques études qui
ont démontré des effets légers
ici on nous parle d'un café santé qui
provoque pas de palpitation ni de baisse
d'énergie si vous voulez pas de
palpitations le café décaféiné c'est
très très bon et on ne parle ici d'un
café concentrateur à mon avis juste le
café ça aide la concentration le caféine
je devrais dire on peut se passer
er d'un oxy
génaire à récupération ça me paraît
quand même des allégations assez
osées pour un produit infuser là
je vois pas pourquoi on ferait ça je
vois pas l'utilité au niveau bienfait
santé globale là de rajouter ces poudres
là
ce qu'on peut
tester scientifiquement des tests des
études pour l'instant on n'a pas fait de
tests sont tant que tel avec le café on
sait ce qu'on met dans le produit on
sait ce qui ressort du produit on sait
comment c'est géré par le système donc à
partir de là on a nos réponses
au-delà des bienfaits à l'aiguille
est-ce que ça goûte bon du café aux
champignons un café aux champignons le
café en tout cas mon café aux
champignons goûte le café je vous mets
au défi de goûter le champignon là
dessus c'est impossible alors voici
quelques réactions de goutteur
si le plaisir de boire un café semble
être au rendez-vous on peut questionner
les bienfaits à léguer alors si vos
papilles sont ravis et que la promesse
vous semble invitante pourquoi ne pas
l'essayer le café aux champignons ne
représente aucun risque pour la santé